PoPour conclure cette semaine
popolitique
onon reçoit le chef de bureau
SéSébastien Bovet et Madeleine
BlBlais-Morin, bonsoir vous deu.
- - Bonsoir bonsoir.
- - Parlons du futurisme et de
QuQuébec. Une très longue missie
àà Monsieur le reçu deux thème:
lele troisième lien qu'il pourfd
avavec des arguments sur une éte
ququ'il a lui-même commandé
ququ'elle aimait sur le tramway,
etet ça on sait que c'est son BI
lele défendant cette missive.
C'C'est un incontournable Monsir
LaLabos mais est-ce que sa voix
poporte encore maintenant il est
dedevenu le plus que ex ex mair.
- - Monsieur Labeaume dit qu'ila
prprendre un pour des médias
pependant les prochaines semains
mamais c'est intéressant parce e
dadans le fond dans cette lettre
ilil dit le fond de sa pensée, e
ququi n'a pas pu dit tout aussia
plplace publique pour ne pas
cocompromettre le tramway. Il dt
enen coulisse qu'il a dite au
gogouvernement Lebeau que le
trtroisième lien à ses yeux ses
mamauvaises idées. Le problème
n'n'est pas leste. La concession
susur la rive sud de Québec
AlAlouettes Halep on est où il
fafaut faire des choses autour s
poponts pour améliorer la
cicirculation.
S'S'il y a le poème de circulatn
c'c'est un autre endroit il
fafaudrait agir là-dessus.
InIntéressant dans ce sens. Este
quque ça va porter?
CÇa produit ça donne des
mumunitions aux antipodes
trtroisième mais c'est ce que
MoMonsieur Labeaume n'a plus
l'l'influence qui a qu'il avait
eueu.
- - Ça reste habitera parce que
rérécemment sondage montre que n
tataux de popularité à des nivex
dede 78 %. Y'a pas beaucoup de
popoliticiens qui pourraient se
vavanter d'un taux de popularité
sesemblable.
MMême s'il est sur la voie de
sosortie de façon imminente, sas
unun politicien populaire. J'avs
l'l'impression que François
LeLegault essayait de minimisera
poportée de sa voix en disant :l
a a le droit à ses opinions, c't
unun citoyen comme un autre...
- - on n'a pas senti ce
reremplacement de Monsieur Legat
popour lui répondre mais voici
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - M. Labeaume n'est plus
mamaire de Québec, mais c'est
unun observateur qui a a le droà
seses commentaires sur le tramwy
etet le troisième lien. Donc
jeje vais en prendre connaissane
etet puis je vais lui répondre
mamais là, je n'en ai pas pris
coconnaissance.
- - Vous allez lui répondre?
- - On va lui répondre,
lele gouvernement va probablemet
lului répondre.
- - C'est même pas ce qu'on lui
réréponde. Ça manque sachant de
pepeu de rapport de force?
- - Monsieur Labeaume est
inincontournable mais faut aussi
quque le gouvernement était prêà
enenfoncer dans la gorge de Régs
LaLabeaume le troisième lien.
MaMalgré le taux de Platter de
RéRégis Labeaume. Le succès de e
LaLabeaume Bruno Massot pale de
prprotection des terres agricols
mamais en partant le troisième
lilien... il y a des terres qui
vovont y passer. Le tramway s'et
imimposé de la rue de Québec ete
trtroisième lien sombre du Québ.
- - Il y a de l'argent du fédérl
AdAdam attend de la part du
QuQuébec?
- - Parlant du troisième je vovs
didirai qu'il n'y a pas un grand
enenthousiasme du côté du
gogouvernement Trudeau non plus.
CeCe que j'entends en coulisse e
gogouvernante n'est pas là pour
bbâtir du béton. Les aspects
coconcernant les transports en
cocommun peuvent être envisagé
mamais Monsieur Legault doit se
trtrouver des partenaires et ce
n'n'est pas si évident pour ce i
esest du troisième lien. Ce qu'n
rérépétait avant la campagne c't
ququ'on n'a pas toujours vu le
prprojet sur la table et ce sert
plplus facile à gérer avant une
cacampagne.
FrFrançois Legault lui aussi trs
popopulaire a dos, maintenant iy
a a beaucoup plus de temps poure
gogouverernement Trudeau pour pd
poposition sur ce sujet.
- - François Legault...
- - c'est au gouvernement de
l'l'éponger parce qu'il est
ququestion de 600 millions de
dodollars de dépassement de coût
acactuellement le gouvernement a
réréagi en disant c'est un homm.
IlIl faut réduire ce dépassement
etet alors que pour le troisième
lilien ça peut coûter 10 millias
ouou des médias, y aura pas de
prproblème à financer. Voyez le
didiscours du goéland du Québec
vivis-à-vis des deux projets.
EnEn effet Monsieur Labeaume ne
veveut pas que ce soit la qui
trtraçabilité siège.
- - On verra si son succès va
prprendre tout ça en charge.
PaParlant de Mélanie Joly. Elle
esest devenue les désinfectants
elelle a rencontré le secrétaire
d'd'État Monsieur Blinken. Ils t
pupu échanger quelques mots en
frfrançais. On a l'impression qe
çaça mais la table à un grand
sosommet. Madeleine aux débats
cocomment vous définissez le déi
popour Mme Joly dans le cadre de
cecette rencontre. Qu'est-ce qun
vava aller chercher un nouveau
CaCanada?
- - On a observé sa rencontre
auaujourd'hui est le véritable
tetest pour le gouvernement
TrTrudeau, c'est la semaine
prprochaine.
TuTu vas être entre juste Trudeu
etet Joe Biden dans une renconte
bibilatérale. Il y aura aussi le
trtrio des trois amis et c'est
trtrès important pour le Canada,
esest très important pour
l'l'industrie de l'auto.
LLà on est content du côté des
trtrois leaders de dit on renoue
avavec la tradition. Il n'y a ps
unune semaine des trois amis sos
lala trompe, mais avait pas dit
quque tout est réglé. Les
irirritants commerciaux ne sont
papas aplanis. On réalise que
c'c'était le gouvernement
dédémocrate aux États-Unis dans
l'l'histoire qui était davantage
prprotectionniste. On le voit
enentre autres avec cette idée e
prpromettre des crédits d'impôt
popour les voitures vertes mais
coconstruites aux États-Unis.
CeCela pourrait compromettre
l'l'industrie de l'auto au Cana.
TrTrudeau en a parlé à Biden Dea
COCOP. C'est sur aides qui vont
emempaler la semaine prochaine t
ququant à l'industrie de l'auto,
onon parle d'une partie du PIB
cacanadien d'une industrie majee
auau pays qu'on a voulu sauver e
rurue négociant lalena
mamais là c'est comme s'il fallt
lele refait. Si on fait mal au
ccôté canadien ça va mieux aux
AmAméricains aussi.
- - Ce qui essayait de 10 Mélane
JoJoly qu'on fabrique une auto.
LeLes pièces ont ramené d'un côé
dede l'autre. En fait ces décèse
coconvaincre que la n'est pas
jujuste les États-Unis mais ausi
lele Nord donc le Canada.
- - C'est comme avec Joe Biden e
toton a changé. C'est moins car.
LaLa philosophie et le fondation
rereste la même. Les États-Unis
veveulent toujours faire du
prprotectionnisme. Même quand un
prprojet accepté par l'altératin
BiBiden comme de transporter
l'l'électricité jusqu'à Boston,a
SaSauveterre de Bayonne a mis sn
popoids pour passer un référendm
auau Massachusetts... dans le me
etet ce n'est pas passé. Il peuy
avavoir des points de tension sr
lala façon dont on intègre les
écéconomies on a l'impression qe
MoMonsieur Biden a protectionnie
auaussi.
- - On avait évoqué mais on
réréalise que dans les faits il
esest vraiment protectionniste.
CeCeci dit un premier sommet
dedepuis 2007 n'est pas rien avc
unun ton qui a complètement
chchangé. Juste le fait de pouvr
sese parler qui a pas quelqu'un
ququi va nous lancer des insult.
- - J'ai l'impression qu'on saià
ququoi s'attendre. Qu'on n'est s
enen train de se dire qu'on va
mamarcher sur une mine
anantipersonnel...
- - ou qu'on aura un tarif impoé
cece quelque chose qu'on n'a pas
vuvu venir?
- - Oui pour des raisons de
sésécurité nationale ce qui a éé
ininsultant pour le Canada.
EnEn travail à découvert avec
dédéfaite la dalle avec une façn
prprotectionniste oui mais sans
lalaisser.
OnOn n'est pas en train de dire
ququ'on va jeter l'ALENA à la
popoubelle mais du côté canadien
n'n'est pas en train de miser gs
mamais ça reste des rencontres
imimportantes. Il faudrait que
cecette bonne entente paye
ququelques part.
IlIl y a aussi une dynamique
imimportante avec les États-Unis
papar exemple les préoccupations
susur l'immigration et va fallor
quque le Canada s'insère là-
dededans.
LeLes préoccupations canadiens e
sosont pas toujours les
prpréoccupations américains. Nos
rereportait canadien on se
prpréoccupe des questions
cacanadiennes mais ce n'est pase
ququi va être l'élément numéro n
susur l'ordre du jour de cette
rerencontre des trois amis.
- - Rencontre le 18 novembre vi.
SiSi on regarde ce qui vient ves
nonous du côté de la scène
ququébécoise assumait susurveile
ququoi Sébastien6
- - de mettre immense la CAQ se
réréunit en conseil génénéral. t
l'l'église de la CAQ demain
didimanche. On va parler des
rérégions : un thème électoral
icici. À Trois-Rivières.
- - De votre côté Madeleine.
- - Il y a aussi un caucus
coconservateur qu'on va suivre
memercredi. On les suit tous ces
tetemps-ci parce que toujours
cecette question de la vaccinatn
obobligatoire des députés pour
rerentrer à la chambre des
cocommunes qu'il préoccupe à
l'l'interne au parti conservate.
OnOn avait le pression que la
sesemaine d'Erin O'Toole c'est
mimieux terminé qu'elle avait
cocommencé. Comme s'il avait
momontré plus : en dénonçant les
prpropos de sa députée qui veut
foformer un mini caucus pour
dédéfendre les droits des non
vavaccinés. Il a rabroué
pupubliquement disant : les
cocommentaires sur la médecine s
AbAbouts les aspects de la sant.
FaFaites des liens entre la polo
etet la COVID c'est délicat. Ila
exexclu de s son cabinet fantôme
totout les dépéputés qui avaiené
leles plus vocaux sur les
crcritiques face à la vaccinati.
OnOn a senti qu'il a montré plu:
mamais comment ça va se transpor
lolors du prochain caucus on va
sosous s